hello podcast listener don't want to
interrupt your fine day i know we have a
big show but we thought we'd
jump in real quick and tell you about
how you can win bonnaroo tickets with a
camping pass berry quarter
this is huge this is uh man i wish i
could uh i wish i could clean up by the
way when you say that i want to see your
hands by the way
i need the hands above the table and you
say this is huge
huge
beyond the screen all right so this is
exciting so you get
in the years past we've basically just
done hey
saying something nice about us now we've
taken the
um
we've gone next level with our vanity
and we want you to make art with our
faces
that's right i need you to i need you to
draw something
about me
okay if and if brad and russ are in the
in there as well that's great
but mostly about me wait a minute oh
it's about barry oh we didn't agree with
that i i mean i think anything what
podcast related if you could whip up
something and
whether it be by hand whether it be on
photoshop whether you know it's a
something you force your child to do
whatever you need
whatever you can do to get these tickets
in your hand that's what we need from
you
yeah yeah okay it'll be fun make it fun
and how do we submit that russ
um send them to uh comments at
thewhatpodcast.com
or you can uh tweet them to us the what
underscore podcast i didn't even know
that was the thing comments at
thewhatpodcast.com
yeah okay
[Laughter]
i have keep sending them is that where
we got the uh the first drawing already
uh first one came to us on twitter i
have to say it's pretty strong i love it
i love my hair it looks very jaunty in
the picture
so it's a great first example of what
we're looking for
maybe we can put it on here for people
to see so they know what they have to be
well you leave it to russ he's got it
going on he's got the thing popped up
that's our first submission do we know
the names of this person the name of
this person rather uh nope ponto wasn't
it gary got it all right there you go
be like gary submit your fine piece of
what podcast art for bonnaroo tickets
we'll do the drawing we'll give it four
weeks you think we can make this happen
in four weeks or we want longer
four weeks put a limit on it given
knowing how we operate i wouldn't put a
deadline on it it's a good point well
we'll pick
a big show today let's do it
[Music]
the what podcast which bands this year
that matter barry corder lord taco brad
steiner uh afternoon guys how are you
how are things you look pretty barry
look well everybody okay
great yeah you're doing great yeah doing
great
okay yep everything's good how are you
you know i don't think i've ever heard
you say yeah i'm just okay
yeah i'm not i'm always good life is
good all right
taco
how's the bus
bus is good just like yeah i'm what you
got in that cabinet what's your name
what's that cabinet let's see let's see
oh you can reach into the cat
you get your own pvr cabinet wow how
about that
stick it back there yep
yeah because you don't want the boss to
see it you don't want to see
no that's why i mean
that's why i'm in the bus hiding out so
this is a exciting week uh for us barry
i think that we have the biggest artist
we've ever had on the show
that's right
am i do you think i'm overstating it you
think i'm blow vehicle oh no no no
no
you know if we're going by the poster
yeah if we're going by our own like
poster if we're making our what show
podcast
festival poster they would probably be
our headliner huh this would be the
headliner okay their second line on some
other other posters but on ours man it's
top
pretty cool
yeah so
it's not really about any festival in
particular although that uh they are
playing boston calling in for castle you
know i i
i'll talk about it afterwards
um
about their interaction with festivals
in general because something about this
conversation sort of struck me and i
i don't think we've ever really uh dove
too far into it because we are we live
in this world
you and i and taco where festivals
really matter
and to some artists
they just don't
yeah you know
well you know i was thinking about that
because we do put a lot of emphasis and
and it's one of the questions that
we've asked for five years which ones do
you like the most
and for the most part they see a bus
they see a backstage
and they see a stage
and then a crowd
uh what's different what is it and then
and then they see a check and then you
see a check and they see a bus and then
they go then they see the road
um
so yeah and and
you know we've asked the question before
which one do you do you uh approach this
festival
differently than the other and of course
the answer is no
who's gonna say yeah we do this one
better you know we put more energy into
this one than that one nobody's gonna
say that well we always because we
personalize it we personalize it because
we think it's a girlfriend you know
which girl do you like better pick one
you have
to but the other thing is and and and we
have heard people say bonner is
different because sometimes they stay
longer
you know they actually go to see other
acts they might stay a day or two
number one but the other thing i was
thinking about is
the the stage and the show and
the 90 minutes are pretty much
they're similar i don't want to say
they're all the same but they're similar
it's what happens away from that 90
minutes that makes one festival
different than the other right
they don't always see that yeah you know
so let's see what you mean yeah oh well
to cut to the chase our uh guest today
rufus the soul uh tyrone from rufus to
seoul and believe me it was all i could
do to not sing call tyrone
while he was talking to us i wanted to
so bad
because how many times do you actually
meet somebody named tyrone not very
often i can't think i've ever met a
tyrone now that i think about it i don't
think i can find a tyrone that i know in
my life except for him
and i so badly wanted to sing but i just
couldn't do it couldn't bring myself to
do it it was great it was really cool
talking to him uh so it's it's pretty
much a standalone uh episode today where
you know we're not going to get into
much festival talk uh we spent a good
25-30 minutes with tyrone from rufus to
seoul talks about the new album talks
about
uh you know what they've been doing the
last two years i love the conversation
about his kid
and how priorities have changed and um
you know i feel like at least i take
from it and i mention it
i hear a lot of mental health things
happening in and around this
conversation not to mention
it did feel as though it was
on the brink of ending did you pick that
up
yeah to be clear to your point they it's
it sounded like they fixed it
they think they're like they're in it
now but they were they were headed
towards as he said a [ __ ] storm yeah and
uh well you'll hear you'll hear it from
him so here we go rufus the soul on the
what podcast enjoy
[Music]
sorry for the delay no it's okay
glad you're here you've got you've got
sunny la life to live you're doing just
fine
how are things great things are great
yeah i gotta imagine so i mean it's not
like you're um
i don't know your band seems to be doing
just okay
you know we've had a good run um
stoked about it we've been together for
like 11 years and it's been a really
smooth uh
i mean smooth it's been a great a great
journey and we're here and i'm yeah i'm
stoked well i will talk about the the
new album the new song of course uh here
in a little bit but i kind of wanted to
start
at bonnaroo 2018
because i don't think that there was a
um a more talked about tent show
afterwards than what you guys pulled off
in 2018. do you have any memories of
that
why i
they all run together don't they they
really do blend in at a certain point
and especially like having not done many
shows over the last three years like
since i think like
2018 and 19 basically shows just came to
a halt for us and we went into the
studio and started writing music and
made the most of
not touring and uh i don't know it's
weird i don't really remember
being on tour like i don't remember much
before it like
you know i do and i remember well no
it's it's it's afterwheel doing a lot of
shows and it's exciting and yeah it's so
it's sort of like the case of the covet
brain right there's life pre-covered and
life post covered and it didn't happen
before it i don't were we even alive did
we do anything
exactly
yeah it's changed so much for us like in
a real positive way i mean we you know
we we've we're hard workers we work a
lot probably workaholics like we we
spend a lot of time making music and
uh it just forced us to slow down a bit
and
i don't know it's a really nice reminder
of
uh the fact that we're friends like
we're three guys that are in the band
and we're best friends we love making
music and
it you know it was a good pause for us
to kind of reset and rethink where we
wanted to go and
i don't know we changed the way we write
too usually it's like in the past it's
been late nights throughout you know
till the morning
just following the creative train hoping
that a song kind of is born out of it
and this time around
we just uh
we had more structure we did more of
like a nine to five only it was
uh 11 to 7 for us to skip the traffic
still not waking up early are you still
not gonna make it harder
oh well i am i'm a dad and i've got i've
got a little two and a half year old son
so i'm up at five at the cracking crack
of dawn yeah well congratulations yeah
that's nice
this is what i kind of wanted to get at
because
you said 11 years and you guys started
in australia and now you're in los
angeles right and you're yeah got a
child
what was what's that transition been
like i mean i know
i was reading a little bit uh
especially about
the the property where you recorded your
first album right sold sold for a nice
little uh bit of change
uh back in australia right because
apparently they sold it as the place
where a roof is uh
recorded right that's kind of funny but
what's it like going
from that
to where you are now
uh as far as like a a band what's that
transition been like over the years
it's surreal i mean i think when we
started out we had dreams and
aspirations that were far smaller than
they are now like you know in australia
we grew up in sydney so it was like to
play the local kind of live venues there
and then as you kind of
grow
our goals and the goal posts shifted and
it's been like a steady climb and i
don't know i guess the biggest
transition has been the last two three
years where we've where i'm a dad now
i'm married and
we we as a band like if we were to
sustain
the way we were going like we had to
change some things this was just like so
many shows
and we were running ourselves into the
ground and
it was compromising the quality of the
shows and
i don't know you know it was also just
like pushing each of us as friends
further apart and so it's just been like
a nice reset that wasn't easy it wasn't
like in the last three years haven't
been easy it's been difficult and
i feel like we're reaping the rewards
just in terms of our friendship and the
music making and
uh
and me just being a
dad too like i i didn't know
i wouldn't have known what i was missing
out on i would have been on the road
being like yeah i'm a great dad and you
know
i wouldn't have known any different and
realistically i wouldn't have been in my
son's life nearly as much and it's been
a big gift but that i get to wake up
next time and
you know like hang out and
and then go make music with with my
friends well you you said that it
switched and changed a little bit of
your priorities you know those shows did
get really massive and you guys did that
on purpose and it
gained you so much traction in in the
community you got such a massive amount
of
of fans throughout the last couple of
years and now it's a switch of the i
guess a little refocus of the priorities
what does the next two years look like
for you guys
i mean
it looks
quite similar really like we're still
we're back in the studio now uh we got
back in there to make more music a few
weeks ago
and
that's our plan like to continue making
music it's what we love to do
uh
you said there was a part of it where it
was almost like tearing you guys apart
you don't want to get back there so what
do you do to you sort of protect
yourself from that kind of experience
again
sure sure i guess it's the amount of
touring we'd go on the road for three
months at a time and then come home
uh now it would look like touring for
four weeks and then coming back for a
week and then touring for four weeks and
coming back for a week and maybe it's a
it's uh
portioned out a little more like spaced
out so you might do like five tours in a
year like across the country across the
globe
and
there's just more space between where we
can kind of reset our clock reconnect
get in the studio
because it's also like you know when
we're on the road
uh
at three months at a time there's no new
music being written like
so that the muscle i see it as a muscle
being in the studio where you're
you know
you're being creative
the longer that you're in the studio the
better you get the sharper your tools
get and maybe you
you know fall on the easy quick fixes or
quick ideas but
for the most part you you're really like
trained like a i don't know like a
someone
in sports that's really sharp at their
their skill in the studio and
it just feels nicer and healthier for us
to be able to
not leave either the live
uh arena for too long or the
the riding arena for too long just
because
yeah
even not
like having a year and a half off
touring coming back and playing our
first show at red rocks
like this year or this year or last year
it was like quite daunting really it was
exciting but we're like are we gonna
know what we get what we do like and we
know how to do this thing
and it
yeah it's like riding a bike you don't
forget but you said it started about
three years ago where you sort of
realized
you needed to do something was there an
event or was it
did you you know was there one night
where you kind of blew up at each other
or could you see it coming and then
covet hit and it gave you the chance to
to fall back and it was kind of a [ __ ]
storm a [ __ ] storm that was growing it
was kind of all directions and all all
things were coming to a head where
you know things were really exciting for
us a lot of
uh exciting things are happening like
you know playing a bunch of festivals in
front of a lot of crowds like big crowds
and
you know i think just
you inherently as an artist put pressure
on yourself to create new things and
make new music and we weren't really
getting that time and
when you're touring so much you're like
your personal life's kind of pushed to
the side a bit uh
so in terms of becoming a new parent for
me that was really difficult
um and i know for the guys too it was
really hard
so it was
an accumulation of a lot of things and
then just having been in a band for 10
years or i guess eight years nine years
at the time
um
yeah i think you just undergo change in
that time period like we were early
twenties when we were
when we got together and
now we've entered our thirties and i
don't know i think you just
change and evolve and priorities change
and shift and
it just gave us the time to kind of uh
talk to each other and reset the clock
and
come at writing from a different
perspective and i don't know i just feel
like great things come out of
doing that as opposed to if we just
steamrolled ahead and i don't think we'd
be here right now well i mean it's sort
of it sort of feels like you know
the way that you're describing it is
that you found not just the way that
this operation works best for you but
also uh maybe even
channeled funneled its way into your
songwriting you know the way that i kind
of describe it as emo edm you know you
guys are so vulnerable you actually put
so much you know actual you know work
into the songwriting part of it which is
the part that i find to be a little bit
more refreshing and it does feel as
though this album is a little bit more
focused on that right
am i reading this yeah sure
no no that's fair i mean all of them
we throw ourselves as much into all of
them and they like kind they're kind of
like a timestamp not like a diary entry
it's like an unintentional time stamp of
where we're at at that moment in time
when we make a record
and i you know some people bands might
you know write the songs go in there and
record in a studio over the course of
like a month or two we're in the studio
writing on our synths and our drums and
like
an unlimited amount of tools kind of at
our disposal to write and create but
we're in there over the course of like a
year a year and a half and that's like
full time just going into the studio
so it's a lot of time that we're
spending on
fishing it's like you go in there and
you can write a bunch of ideas and they
could all be crap but occasionally you
just like stumble on a really real raw
song that
uh
reflects where we're at and it is
vulnerable and it usually is
i feel like when we're at our best is
when we're like you know we tap into
something that's vulnerable but also
hopeful and
it feels it i don't know it feels good a
lot of my favorite bands like radiohead
um
they do that it's like this
uh hopeful
disease discomfort euphoria but it's
like just treads a line that
yeah i just think it's really exciting
yeah given given all that how much did
it change over if you had that much time
did the final sound sound like what it
did when you started or
did what you what you were doing when it
started
completely go away or did you keep some
of that
you know what i mean uh we had a lot of
creative freedom going in because we
didn't have a deadline like touring was
wiped off so it wasn't like we had oh
we've got two weeks to write a song
right it was kind of like all right we
went to joshua joshua tree we were in
this ranch type thing which is a studio
um
it's called escape studios and it was
awesome like it's in the middle of
nowhere and it was just us
and we you know would start the day with
meditation
uh to exercise get in a cold plunge and
then
by midday we'd get in there and and
write music it was just a really cool
way to do it and we were trying
different beats for ourselves uh and
different tempos and different
instruments i think it was more like
classical songwriting where we're just
trying to write songs without
producing them or seeing them all the
way to the finish line
and then you kind of like end up with
little gems and then you over the course
of the next
six months a year you're trying to
crack the code on them and finish them
and
we
always go into an album without a clear
intention of what it's going to end up
like it's more like what's inspiring us
at the time what are you guys listening
to we share a bunch of music
we
listen through the you know albums that
have inspired us across our years
like we'd listen to an album while we
did exercise every every day
uh over the course of that two months
and
you know that bleeds into the record
being in joshua tree where it's like uh
it essentially feels like you're on the
moon
like it's just like rock outcrops
like that all influences things you say
you sound so
mentally centered
is this a reflection of of the work that
you've done or do you guys were you guys
all this always sort of this
you know
buddhist
mentally yeah no no we weren't we
weren't always like that you know like
we were we were young and
silly and
we've always cared about our live shows
we've always cared about making the
music but you know we had a lot of fun
across the years i like you know before
we walked out on stage uh five six years
ago we were having a whiskey shot you
know before walking out i did one just
now
good
and now we do ginger shots before we
walk out it's just like you know it's
it's where we're at now and i hear you
yeah i mean it is definitely more built
for the long haul so
this this sound um you know
you're not talking to somebody who knows
what he's talking about when it comes to
this no so so bear with me for a second
um but when you were a kid and you were
playing around and saying to yourself i
want to make a band i want to i want to
do this
uh how did you
stumble upon
making electronic music
how did you make
how did you find that world instead of
how a kid would normally just pick up a
guitar and start writing songs like that
well honestly that's where i started was
with the guitar i i started on piano
when i was like five um and then kind of
moved into playing in bands when i was
12
and
i always just wrote music kind of from
14 i used any software i could get my
hands on and just recorded more
alternative kind of uh
i guess like acoustic
just songs really it was just fun for me
and
the three the three of us produce and
write the songs and we all have a
different story as to how we ended up
like
you know making the songs we make
but for me uh
that was it and i met one of the john
one of the other guys
and he was making more club music i
guess and we kind of
met in the middle and we were like oh
you you guys you like book of shade and
there was a few acts that we bonded over
and chemical brothers oh cool yeah we
love i like that and then we just
started making some songs and
uh
you know we would share our production
our tools with each other and
there was a healthy push and pull and
there has been between all three of us
in terms of
uh where we want to take a song and that
you know for me i'm probably more
influenced
originally by rock or
you know and john probably more so like
club songs he has an appreciation for
pop and everything and james he's kind
of
he loves
he loves all music he's polka it's polka
yeah i know it he's the glue he's the
glue he's like he's just a yeah he's the
yellow seven i feel like they're like in
every thing you need like a yellow seven
that brings all the compounds together
um so
there there
there is a big difference i guess in
your maybe there's not when it comes to
like the live show versus the recorded
product i've always wondered this and
and again you're talking to an idiot so
i apologize up front but when you're on
stage and i know that you're doing you
know mostly you know vocals and
keyboards and stuff but when
i'm watching an electronic artist on
stage how much freedom
is actually happening in that space
is it
some of it's premixed i understand but
what in it
is controllable and
maneuvered and
worked out on stage in the moment
between the two or three of you rather
well it depends on the act but for us in
particular like
we like to build out our sets and lock
it in pretty solidly in terms of
you know we see the lights in our show
as an important tool and asset it's kind
of like the fourth member of the band
um but we don't want it to just be a
lighting show when we play so
we like the interaction of it being a
band that can jam out and kind of stay
on a loop for however long we want and
we can improvise and there are moments
where there are drum solos and
it it's kind of
it's evolved as well
when we started we had less freedom to
be able to jam on stage and now we've
built that in what would because for
your own comfort
no no not so much well i mean set times
you only really get 25 minutes 30
minutes at the start of your career like
it's like go play three songs and come
off
um
so you're basically just playing them
verbatim but now
i don't know we've just got more tools
in terms of equipment uh more know-how
in terms of how to go about things how
to go on a loop and stay there and how
that is all synced together in terms of
our lights in front of house like the
team that is
you know
in the from the audience's perspective
how is it
staying
in time like
uh
[Music]
yeah that's a bit of like a
it's a challenge to know how to do that
i'm definitely not very tech savvy to be
able to go oh this is how you do it sure
like it's been a learning process and
there are many ways to go about it but
it seems to me like if it's not coming
in with like a pre-mix and you guys are
just sort of like putting your vocals
and some effects around it it does feel
as though sort of like a high-wire act
that you're pulling off if you're you're
doing loops
on the fly and you guys are all just
sort of you know seeing where the moment
takes you is that right
i mean we're not like a jam band so it's
not right now saying that no i know i
know
it's more like i guess we build it in so
it's not like hey are you guys feeling
uh a jam right now it's kind of like
we've allocated ourselves times and
moments in the set where it's like
here's the part where we're gonna go on
like a one minute like and it's not
necessarily a myth but however long
we've pre-set how long it's going to be
where it's like we can jam out and we
can loop something we can and there's
freedom for us to do what we want i was
gonna ask how much how much of that
comes from trust from having done it
with each other for so long
yeah a lot of it and it's like it
a lot of it is trust and it's like a
language i i guess right after doing it
for so long with each other it's like we
don't really need to say
okay i'm gonna take this little moment
here or
yeah it's a it's more fluid and
you know we get time to rehearse and
so
it's not as like
yeah i would just say we're not a jam
band we're in a lot electronic act
we make alternative
electronic music and
but we know how to play our instruments
and we know how to jam so the reason the
reason i bring that up is because i
adore the xx i love them and i think
that you know they're one of my favorite
you know bands on the planet but that
live show is um almost like jamie has
hit play and it's over when the track is
done
you know
yeah you know sometimes i'm just
watching jamie just stand back there i'm
like alright i don't really have much to
do back here
yeah well that's exactly what i mean by
like it depends on the act like there
are so many uh acts that
have different setups in terms of
there's so many ways to go about it and
a really important thing for us was
having live drums we knew that that's
that was you asked it before you're like
how did you get into electronic music
that is how i saw acts from australia
like cut copy and i love text
i love yeah great
and it's just like they they had
they would do it it sounded like a band
but it was electronic music and i was
like oh maybe i
maybe i like electronic music this is
just like rock but in
yeah and and it kind of opened the
gateway of me being a little more
open-minded because electronic music
lately nothing has screwed up old white
guy
more than seeing a hip-hop band with a
band
watching a rapper perform with a band
you know he's sitting there wanting to
hate they don't even play their own
instruments oh wait they're playing
instruments so
i want to go back if i can real quick to
the album because i'm interested i'm
fascinated by this idea of you not
having a deadline and you're having all
that time because we've talked about
this on here many many times with acts
this whole process of writing
you've got some bands that love that
deadline they love the pressure you know
they can turn around and make it happen
and do it in two or three weeks
whereas if you have unlimited time
it seems to me like it'd be easy to just
get lost you know
yesterday was done and over now i want
to do something new or what i'm feeling
this week is completely different than
last week or
two three months ago how how do you keep
that focus
and it's definitely a ch it's it's a
challenge like i that is what we
experience like we're kind of like
we feel a certain way about a song and
you know we're excited by certain things
today and then in six months time that
changes and
the production can change on the song
and your perspective on the song that
you wrote six months ago could change
and
and some stand the test of time and some
don't and
we've got a vault of
uh skeleton songs that haven't stood the
test of time
and
you know that we haven't put out
so it's kind of been a gift in a way
that it takes us so long to write music
because
most of the songs that end up on an
album we've been sitting with them for
like six plus months
that's different
and love them so it's like
you have
yeah it feels good to let go of it and
let it into the world and
you know where you sit with it and
sure maybe in five years time i might be
like oh i don't like that song but i
mean yeah it's we've given it a chance
and we've given it time
but there is a process of losing
yourself in the mud and
there's
yeah it you can easily get lost and
for us what was helpful is taking a
break like we'd take a two-week break
walk away it yeah come back walk away
put it come back you know it's it's such
a simple concept barry but i haven't
really thought about it that way if i
was if i did this for a living and i was
a songwriter i'm so impetuous i would i
would walk into a studio just in a bad
mood one day and be like all right i'm
writing a song about being in a bad mood
and then two days later i'm like i don't
even remember what i was talking about
there like what was that what was i so
upset about it
and i'm just sitting here thinking if
you got a you know a toddler man they
change from week to week to week so
you know you're talking about me again
aren't you barry yeah you're talking
about me right so i know what you're
going through
[Laughter]
but yeah that cha i mean you know a a
two week old is completely different
human being than a two-month-old or a
one-year-old so your whole world's
changing so that's why it's so
fascinating to me
sure that thanks that is it is really
fascinating we actually got uh ziggy my
son like there's a little recording that
i got of him before he could say any
words
and
i just found his voice so cute i'm sure
every parent does when their kids kind
of bother googling
but uh like i recorded it on on my phone
and uh we we managed to squeeze him into
one of the songs on our album
uh called make it happen he's just at
the end of the song and
it just makes me happy like the little
that's called trinkets and what do you
call it uh easter eggs that are in the
album
but you know
they they kind of come out of making an
album for a year and a half
yeah
that's really great if we made an album
berry we would just have random sound
effects of
taco opening a pbr you know just
randomly for no reason yeah here it is i
know
drinking beer all right so this is
something we do on occasion uh first off
thank you so much for spending so much
time with us and and you know dealing
with um you know at least in one
particular person mine not knowing what
the hell i'm talking about uh but what i
i want to play a little game that we
usually do with with uh some people
predictive texts what podcasts predicted
predictive texts so basically i put in
to google
does rufus desole and i let the google
predictive text finish the sentence for
me right so i'm going to ask you a bunch
of questions from the google predictive
text okay
so does rufus de soul song
yes yes good okay
hard man they sound hard they song hard
is rufus to seoul edm
well
i i i don't like i don't like uh the
word idiom we're electronic music and it
is dance music so okay
what does rufus the soul mean in english
that that's what it means
that's what it means in english
look these are absurd things here i like
this one is rufus the soul pregnant
there was a time period where uh we were
just rufus and yeah a lot of people
thought it was just one guy but what's a
curveball with that is that
rufus do so i'm like a female
like definitely not a guy if they're
pregnant
and then finally the uh the thing about
uh i think that you're so endearing to
the the bonus
audience is because rufus is
the what do they call those things
that's that's like the the mascot of
bonnaroo is rufus
but it's spelled r-o-o-f-u-s
it's three circles of the smiley face so
uh you know you you sort of like have an
automatic in with the bonnaroovians
that's so good yes yeah the figure the
animated figure rufus it was the long
play we knew it
yeah you know the whole time
[Laughter]
there is one other thing that and
probably not in your department and you
probably don't know anything about it
because you know i'm sure you don't
spend much time you know worrying about
booking but you know you had
yeah the 2018 bonnaroo you did coachella
two years in a row then you were going
to come back for the second version of
bonnaroo when it got rescheduled to
labor day uh that fell apart this year
this tour that you are embarking on is
has two festivals on it boston calling
and four castle
was there any sort of conversation about
why those two festivals and not a
bonnaroo again or a coachella again
and if you weren't part of that then
don't worry about it i just i thought
that it was a it was an interesting set
of tour dates i saw
yeah i mean
i can't remember the conversation but i
know that we've had it uh but i guess
like you're booking shows
like a year out so those conversations
were like six months ago um
but
i don't know why it made sense at the
time sure um fine by me yeah in terms of
like you know
playing the same festival again and
again it's like
of course like you have your favorite
festivals and your personal love for
festivals but
there are different crowds and different
people and it's a real opportunity for
us to get into in front of new ears to
play a new festival or a different
festival as opposed to you know i feel
like most festivals have their
loyal fans and
you know you play one hopefully
i just think alternating between
festivals is healthy for us as a band
and
but you know we obviously have our
favorites person for somebody who's
actually done this overseas and in
america can you tell a marked difference
between the european festivals and the
festivals overseas than american
festivals what is the difference for you
uh we haven't done so much in europe i
mean we've done a lot of stuff over
there but we haven't played many
festivals over there um
in australia i could speak in terms of
australia they're quite similar really i
mean it's just that australia's a lot
smaller of a market
not in terms of land mass but in terms
of population
who's your favorite australian artist
australian artist tame impala ah okay i
was hoping to say courtney barnett it's
amazing how many australian artists have
exploded uh over the last 10 years right
whereas before
there weren't i mean it just was not a
fertile ground of our
bands coming out of australia and then
out of nowhere
it feels like every time i turn around
there's another australian band making
you know some sort of noise
that's true courtney barnett is is
really amazing she's such a good
storyteller and there is just so many
great acts that are coming out of
australia i i don't know
there's a nationwide radio station in
australia called triple j and it's it's
like an alternative radio station that
you can hear you know hip-hop to heavy
metal to
something more poppy uh to indie rock
and roll
yeah and it's just like the full
spectrum
and i'd say for the most part that's
what
if you're growing up that's what you're
listening to as a kid and
so i think a lot of the
a lot a large portion of australians are
growing up listening to a wide variety
of music and i don't know what that does
for a brain or like your taste in
music or
how that affects your influence in terms
of what you want to write but i think
that has something to do with it oh yeah
if i was to guess oh yeah
did it help foster an environment where
you felt like you could come from
australia and make it
you know what i mean sure that's a huge
part of
being i think we weren't even looking
outside of australia though i think that
it was like the opportunity that you
could have your song on triple j
like in australia it's like oh my god if
we get a song on there then the whole
country can potentially hear your song
and that means you could tour to you
know the six biggest cities and you
potentially play these festivals that
you know about
it's it's so small over there like that
it's
it's it's doable like it's like you can
do it and that's what i mean that's good
seaberry radio still matters damn it
radio still matters maybe not here but
it matters
matters somewhere
man tyrone thank you so much for the
time i uh i'm so excited to see you guys
um
you know and it's been wonderful to
watch you guys explode over the last
couple of years i think the new singles
terrific and the new album so much fun
to listen to i can't wait to see it live
man
thank you so much thanks for having me
and yeah it's great to chat i enjoy your
time see you soon
[Music]
yeah uh there you go rubus is sold
tyrone you better
call
tyrone uh on the what podcast i uh
really the thing about him
is that what it's just a sweetheart yeah
and i feel as though if you know i
didn't constantly interrupt he would
have just talked forever
yeah yeah yeah he was a one he's a one
question interview
how are you yeah barry loves those mary
loves those those are great barry's
barry's go-to move on something like
that if you ever notice i'll pull the
curtain back his go-to move is
uh
well with the new album did you
accomplish everything you wanted
and then just let the person go for 45
minutes and all right got my story see
you later it's actually a two-parter
what did you hope to accomplish and did
you do it
that's a pro tip right there now you're
giving journalism 101 kids you're
getting uh you're getting a master class
here from very giving my secrets away
[Laughter]
works every time by the way if if you
ever hear barry say that either he knows
exactly where he's going with it or he
has nothing
again you're giving all my good stuff
away
i really liked it though i mean mainly
because look i i i don't i'm not gonna
pretend i know much about electronic
music i just it's not something i ever
really engaged with but i do find rufus
is so interesting because you know
they're one of the few ones that that
operates it like a band
um and the way that he described it
although i'm sure it was mind-numbing
for him to explain it to some sort of
idiot like me but
it really helps me sort of understand
you know and the gist i was getting to
barry was
dumb guys like me
think that you walk up there with a
laptop and you hit play
right
now they're actually playing they remind
me and i always you know i always
hesitate to compare
but it reminds me a lot of uh early
allen parsons project stuff which i love
um
so yeah i liked it i like it a
yeah
lot
says
it was interesting to hear him talk
about process i'm really fascinated by
that whole having a year and a half to
create an album that just seems to me
like it would brain lock somebody yeah
because at the end of the day you can
give me a year and a half i'm still
gonna wait to the last two weeks and the
song that i come up with is going to be
word word word word word word where do
you word a word word word exactly
exactly yeah and the thing we did in a
year and a half ago i'm over it i
remember what i did two weeks ago
a year and a half ago
so did you find it interesting that um
and this is not a shot but
he really doesn't know one festival from
the other
that's what i'm saying
a bus a road a stage a bus a road to
stay
and there's really nothing wrong with
that especially if the show is good but
you know
it makes me wonder if that's how
mccartney is most days you know he said
where the hell am i knoxville all right
i guess so who cares well guys like guys
like that are are very uh intentional
now about what they do from what i've
heard they don't they do the shows they
want they've done it enough they know
how to travel
but you did hear him say is you're
talking about the mental health thing
before it was road road road road road
and now they're very uh again
intentional about whatever you know
instead of three months
maybe four weeks and then come off so
well the other thing too is that i i
found to be refreshing is
and this is not again not a knock on the
people that we've talked to before but
we have talked to plenty of artists
where it feels like they are in control
of everything
almost to like uh almost almost to a
problematic place where you can't get a
show past them they know every person
that's in part of the operation they've
got their hands in everything uh he
feels it sounds to me like the way that
he operates like oh you guys just do
that i'll uh go be writing songs here
yeah well a two-year-old would do that
to you yeah that's a good point yeah in
part
good point i'd rather be home yeah
it changes things i mean no question it
was fun to hear him talk about that i uh
the other thing that i found interesting
was
how
without saying it you know i think that
there are plenty of bands that spend a
lot of time
going overboard with the mental health
thing although it is very important and
it should be something that's celebrated
you know it's almost become
to me it's like oh i know i get it it's
important
they're doing it in a very interesting
way it's not preachy and it's not
telling you that mental health is
important saying no no this was on us we
got our stuff figured out and we we
fixed whatever
issues that were going on and
you know yeah a shot of whiskey versus a
shot of ginger i mean it's like it's
like you said they've they were heading
towards
something bad and said we got to fix it
and they've done it so
you know everybody's different
but it's good for them for and i meant
to ask him
you know how who led that sort of
change did they all three come together
or was outside sources says you guys
need to fix this or all of that or
or whatever but uh well yeah you you
then don't you lead on to a good point
because it takes all three to be a part
of something like that it can't just be
like one person saying
you gotta what the the wife always says
is like you gotta the person's gotta
find yoga you can't like force them into
it right so
uh and it's almost like therapy you
can't force somebody to go therapy they
gotta find it on their own time and it's
weird that they all sort of seem to find
it at the same time yeah be like you'd
be like you were me saying taco no more
pbr you need to do a shot of ginger
well we've decided we're going to do
ginger shots instead
i'm i'm hanging up well i'm glad we
brought i'm glad you brought that up
because taco we've been meaning to talk
to you about a few things oh
oh no it's good i drink high life now
[Laughter]
you have changed i have changed
i've given up i've given up kids i've
given it up i'm moving on
dad is back
all right well uh i really you make a
good point it takes all three of them it
would have taken all three of them so
i uh i really appreciate that and
there's he gave us way too much time and
i really do think that the the song the
other thing too i guess that's what i i
tried to dance around without i'm just
not smart enough to come out and just
find a clever way of asking it but
you have this massive following they
sold 50 000 tickets for an la show they
had to add two more dates to they've got
a billion streams they're a massive
massive operation and
they've done it all
you know completely
you know underground you know
underground meaning with no real radio
support no you're not playing them are
you well we just started yeah
their new singles actually really really
good but you know they did it all just
sort of you know the 2020 version of
doing this you know streaming and
um
you know i i find it to be an incredible
story
you know it
panics me a little bit because they
don't they don't need us
they don't need us
they got to take care of themselves
nice well
it's pretty cool
very i enjoyed it a lot anything else
before we go
nope
okay
all right well
i got nothing oh did we figure out do we
figure out what we're gonna do with the
tickets yeah we talked about it on the
last episode barry we were talking about
how we were gonna do it and and we
already have you know we already have a
leader in the clubhouse we have our
first entry yeah the first entry in the
draw high i know that yeah but guys
that happened two weeks ago remember
okay
yeah
i don't know if you guys remember but
that happened so long ago never mind
bye bye guys
[Music]
consequence podcast network